.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
SPEAKING OUT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
THUS BEGAN FOX SENIOR STRATEGIC
ANALYSIS GENERAL JACK KEANE.
LET'S START WITH YOUR THOUGHTS
ON WHERE WE STAND, DAY 11 MOVING
IN TODAY 12 WITH THIS WAR.
YOUR OVERVIEW?
>> WE ARE 12 DAYS INTO THIS AND
CERTAINLY IN THE RUSSIANS MIND
THEY THOUGHT THIS WAS TAKE 2 - 3
DAYS IN THE UKRAINE'S WOULD LAY
DOWN AND NOT FIGHT AND THEY ONLY
COMMITTED A THIRD OF THE FORCES
THAT THEY HAD DEPLOYED INTO THE
AREA AND THE FACILITY OF
UKRAINE.
WE ARE 12 DAYS IN AND THEY
HAVEN'T TAKEN A MAJOR CITY.
UKRAINIAN AIRCRAFT IS STILL
FLYING AND THAT ABSOLUTELY STUNS
ME THAT THE RUSSIANS HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO GAIN SUPERIORITY
AND TAKE THE UKRAINIAN AIRCRAFT
DOWN AND SOME OF THE DEFENSE
SYSTEMS.
THE CYBER ATTACK WHICH IS AN
INSTRUMENT OF NATIONAL POWER
THAT THE RUSSIANS ARE VERY GOOD
AT AND WE HAVE SENSED THAT THEY
ARE GOOD AT IT HAD NEGLIGIBLE
EFFECTS ON THIS CAMPAIGN.
THEIR CASUALTIES ARE WAY HIGHER
THAN ANYBODY'S EXPECTATIONS.
I THINK THEY ARE BEING VERY
DECEPTIVE ABOUT IT.
THEY HAD SUCCESS IN THE SOUTHERN
CAMPAIGN BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
DENY UKRAINE'S ACCESS TO THE
BLACK SEA BUT STILL THEY HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO IN THAT CAMPAIGN
IN THE NORTHERN CAMPAIGN WHICH
IS ABOUT KYIV AND KHARKIV, THAT
HAS STALLED AND THEY TRIED TO
RESTART A NUMBER OF TIMES AND
THEY HAVE NOT MADE ANY
CONSEQUENTIAL PROGRESS.
WHAT THE INTENT TO DO IS GO WEST
AND EAST AVENUE KYIV ENCIRCLED
THE CITY ENFORCE A CAPITULATION
OF THE GOVERNMENT.
EITHER THEY SURRENDER OR THEY
CAPTURE THEM.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN CLOSE TO THAT.
IT IS STUNNING WHERE WE ARE.
12 DAYS IS ONLY 12 DAYS, WARS
LAST A LOT LONGER THAN THAT.
GIVEN WHAT MOST OF US BELIEVE
WAS A SIGNIFICANT OVER MASSIVE
THE RUSSIANS HAD THAT THEY
CERTAINLY WOULD'VE MADE A LOT
MORE PROGRESS IN THIS.
THIS IS TESTIMONY SOLELY TO THE
UKRAINIANS AND THEIR
DETERMINATION.
BUT ALSO HOW MUCH THEY HAVE
IMPROVED SINCE 2014 IN TERMS OF
THE MILITARY AND THE LEADERSHIP
THAT THEY HAVE.
WE ARE HELPING THEM WITH WEAPONS
AND I THINK WE CAN DO MORE AND
WE'VE GOT TO DO MORE.
IF THIS LAST LONGER, THEY WILL
RUN OUT OF ALL THESE TOOLS THAT
ARE BEING SO EFFECTIVE ON THE
RUSSIANS IN MANY OF THESE TOOLS
LIKE STINGERS AND ANTITANK
WEAPONS ARE COMING FROM THE
UNITED STATES AND NATO ALLIES.
AND WE WILL HEAR PRESIDENT
ZELENSKY SCREAMING FOR THEM
BECAUSE HE WILL RUN OUT THEM AS
THIS CAMPAIGN CONTRACTS.
STEVE: LET'S PICK UP ON THAT.
A COUPLE OF DAYS AGO I RECORDED
A CONVERSATION WITH NEIL
FERGUSON.
WE'RE GONNA PLAY A COUPLE OF
CLIPS.
WHAT ARE THE THINGS THAT HE
SAID, HE DREW FORWARD AND SAID
IF WE CAN HELP THE UKRAINIANS
HANG ON FOR A FEW WEEKS.
A FEW MORE WEEKS THEN YOU CAN
SEE A SITUATION WHERE THERE IS
NO PROSPECT THAT PUTIN HAD
ACHIEVED IN THE VICTORY THAT HE
WANTED.
YOU GET TO THE STALEMATE AND
THINGS COULD CHANGE.
YOU MIGHT HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT HE
IS NOT WHAT YOU GET AWAY WITH
IT.
BUT THE KEY TO THAT IS GIVING
THE UKRAINIANS ENOUGH EQUIPMENT
SO THEY CAN HANG ON FOR ANOTHER
FEW WEEKS.
DO YOU SHARE THAT ANALYSIS?
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
PUTIN HAS SERIOUS PROBLEMS HERE,
WE COULD DISMISS THE IDEA RIGHT
NOW THAT PUTIN WOULD BE ABLE TO
SUSTAIN AN OCCUPATION OF UKRAINE
A 45 MILLION PEOPLE OVER TIME,
HE WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO DO
THAT, WE SEEN THE EVIDENCE OF
THAT HERE.
HE DOES NOT HAVE THE FORCES TO
OCCUPY A COUNTRY OF 45 MILLION
PEOPLE, NOT EVEN CLOSE AND GIVEN
THE CASUALTIES HE'S GOT HERE,
THAT IS PRETTY SERIOUS.
THE OPTION IS THERE.
WHAT WERE TALKING ABOUT HERE IS
VERY REAL.
WE CAN IMPOSE SIGNIFICANT COST
ON HIM OVER TIME AND THE
POLITICAL SITUATION MAY CHANGE
AS A RESULT.
WHAT WE THINK PUTIN IS GOING TO
DO, HE IS GOING TO PUMMEL
CIVILIAN POPULATION.
HE WILL HAVE A LOT MORE SUCCESS
IN THE CIVILIAN POPULATION
REGRETTABLY AND HAMMERING WITH
ARTILLERY THEN HE IS HAPPY WITH
UKRAINE MILITARY.
HE WANTS TO BREAK THE WILL OF
THE POPULATION AND BREAK THE
WILL OF ITS LEADERS BY KILLING
AS MANY OF THEM AS THEY CAN.
I THINK HE IS GOING TO REACH OUT
AND SAY SANCTIONS ARE AN ACT OF
WAR, PROVIDING WEAPONS TO THE
ADVERSARY IS ALSO AN ACT OF WAR.
HE'S GOING TO THREATEN THE
EXPANSION OF THE CAMPAIGN TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING THAT.
CERTAINLY CYBER IS THE EASIEST
THING FOR HIM TO USE IN GOING
AFTER THE SANCTIONS.
HE HAS A SIGNIFICANT CYBER
CAPABILITY THAT SUPPLIED AGAINST
US IN THE PAST.
WE WILL LIKELY SEE HIM DO THAT
AGAIN.
WE HAVE GOT TO GET ALL OF THIS
ARMS AND EQUIPMENT INTO THEM ON
A REGULAR SUSTAINED BASIS.
I ALSO THINK WE COULD USE SOME
COVID OPERATIONS TO HELP
FACILITATE DELIVERING THAT
EQUIPMENT, AIR DROPPING SOME OF
IT.
WE HAVE MEANS TO DO THAT AND
ALSO THE AIRFIELDS THAT ARE VERY
REMOTE AND THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE
LIGHTS ON THEM, THEY'RE ALL OVER
UKRAINE LIKE THEY ARE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO TO SPEED IT UP AND GET IT
INTO HIS HANDS.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO PRESS
OUR ALLIES ON THIS AS WELL.
OUR COMMITMENT WE MADE, WE ARE
NOT GOING TO DEFEND THEM ON THE
GROUND.
OUR COMMITMENT, WE ARE ALL IN.
WE WILL NOT LET THIS STAND.
THAT MEANS WE HAVE TO STEP UP.
IT HAS IMPROVED OVER WHAT IT
WAS.
WE DELAYED THESE ARMS AND 2021
BECAUSE WE WERE AFRAID THE
UNITED STATES IF WE GAVE THEM
THE WEAPONS WHEN HE WAS
MOBILIZING AN UKRAINE'S BORDER
THAT WOULD PROVOKE THE ATTACK.
THAT IS SHAMEFUL AND A LACK OF
SPYING TO COME TO A CONCLUSION
LIKE THAT.
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT I
TOTALLY AGREE UKRAINIANS KNOW
FULL WELL THAT THEY ARE DRAGGING
THIS OUT OVER TIME AS MUCH TO
THEIR FAVOR TO BE SURE.
STEVE: EXACTLY WE NEED TO BE
THERE.
IT'S FANTASTIC TO HAVE YOU